let's go next to our caller
from area code 774
who's calling today from 774 and where
are you calling from just as importantly
hey david uh this is max from uh
hopkinton math
max from hopkinton you know i've never
been to hopkinton but i do see the signs
on the turnpike
what what is hopping hopkinton like
uh it's nice it's a small little town
you know small c
mass town uh the start of the boston
marathon is usually how most people know
it by
right all right very good well what's on
your mind today
gotcha so i know you've been stressing
like a lot about how
um you know we should i guess you know
get by in an office more so to get trump
out
and i've always been told like my whole
life how you know everyone's vote
matters but i've been told
by those same people how that vote might
not matter if you vote uh independent
and i understand that in the context of
this election you're you know your
answer is going to be different but i
was wondering what your opinion is on
that
no my my vote my my position is the same
every election every vote matters no
matter who you vote for or if you don't
vote the question
is what is your political objective and
does your vote support that objective or
does it take away from it
so because we have a first pass the post
voting system
rather than single transferable vote or
other ranked choice voting systems etc
if you don't like trump and you vote
third party
you're helping trump in a practical
sense now
if you vote in a state that like
massachusetts which will go to biden
you can make the case that you're not
really helping trump by voting third
party and that's a respectable case to
make
and then on top of that what would be
different this time around is
given that donald trump is so likely to
claim it was rigged
i think it's important to try to run the
score up in blue states
and in red states whether biden has a
shot or not
let's try to build the largest number of
of just raw
vote totals we can for joe biden so it's
not
i i disagree with the idea that it's
different this election i think your
vote always matters
and not voting matters it has an effect
and we need to understand
what that effect is totally awesome i
think that was a great answer really
appreciate it and uh good luck on the
one nil
all right thank you yes very much
appreciate that things looking very
solid from the standpoint of a million
subscribers as of right now
we're at about 980 000 subscribers so we
may have
very powerful news on that for people
sooner than later
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor magic
spoon who have done something awesome
they've taken
all of our favorite sugary childhood
cereals that we know we shouldn't eat
anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n